berlin hier und leon schwarz baum
geborenen zwanzigster februar 1921 vor
100 jahren
heute ist ein besonderer tag für henry
ihn seine freunde nennen empfang beim
bundespräsidenten nur für ihn allein der
überlebenskünstler auf dem weg ins
schloss bellevue es wird im leben die
mir genommen als gegeben
leon liebt dieses lied und den jüdischen
sänger josef schmidt da war auch der
lieblingssänger meiner eltern
wer steht
hätten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist ja mal unser gästebuch eintragen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
freue mich sie zu sehen wir dürfen uns
leiten ein bisschen hinein berührt mich
wirklich sehr vielen dank ihnen dass sie
gekommen sind dann ist
der in schwarz baum hat unvorstellbares
grauen erlebt ausgrenzung schläge gewalt
willkür hunger das ghetto seine eltern
sind in auschwitz ermordet worden er ist
der einzige überlebende seiner familie
und begeht jetzt seinen hundertsten
geburtstag
lee und schwarz baum lebt in seinem
eigenen haus in west berlin seine frau
starb vor einigen jahren versorgt wird
er von freunden und eine pflegekraft
gäste bewirtet er allein den kaffee
macht er selbst im wohnzimmer empfängt
leon seine besucher blickt für bild bei
marmorkuchen mit schlagsahne und frisch
gebrühtem kaffee auf sein langes leben
zurück hamburg altona
da hat er mein vater ein geschäft in
hamburg und meine mutter wollte zu ihrer
familie nach hause nach wohl sind sie
eines tages tatsächlich sagt holen
gefahren mit wies zusammen nach benzin
das oberschlesien in der nähe von
kattowitz
eine kleine stadt wie war bewohnt
hauptsächlich mit juden
da war ich damals vier jahre alt war
eine glückliche kindheit in der familie
im haus in benzin lebte leon zusammen
mit der oma seiner mutter und vater
josef bei einem betten fabriken hier wie
ich gewohnt sie dann ein zimmer
wir haben da und decken steppdecken
gestellt und wir haben sie geliefert
nach kattowitz katowice war ungefähr 20
30 kilometer entfernt und hier konnte
ich durch den garten ruhig länder bild
das haus gehen
da war ich in der schule eine wunderbar
eingerichtet der schule ja ich hab sie
ja das war meine klasse mit 18 jahren
machte leon seinen abschluss es ist das
jahr des deutschen überfalls auf polen
1939 kurz danach nachdem ich abitur
gemacht habe und erhalten habe ist der
krieg ausgebrochen
leons heimatstadt wird besetzt von den
deutschen juden werden verfolgt ermordet
auch die synagoge in bern sind geht in
flammen auf
das erste was genommen haben war die
synagoge und granaten reingeschmissen
und die thora die da drin war dies dann
gerettet worden
die in der kirchenmann von bentley
benzin von der christlichen gemeinde hat
münchen auch retten gerettet in der zeit
[Musik]
mit diesem tor habe ich sie mannes war
gelesen und kann muss sich vorstellen
wie lange der scheibe mit der hand das
geschrieben
[Applaus]
die verfolgung der juden und der polen
wird immer gnadenloser täglich gibt es
neue verordnungen was ich juden verboten
wird kinos schulen parks sie werden zur
zwangsarbeit abkommandiert pure schikane
1940 errichten die deutschen das ghetto
auch leons familie wird umgesiedelt und
bevor da und dahin zu ziehen
wir haben so einen kleinen wagen genieße
und wir haben die sachen unesco über
geschafft
1943 das ghetto wird geräumt
hitlers end lösung ist in berlin
angekommen und erreicht auch leons
familie und dass ich eines morgens
glaubt dass an der tür raus raus raus
raus raus das ging alles blitzschnell
so das war einfach keine zeit hat sich
überhaupt zu sammeln
wenn man morgens geweckt und gleich
nackt und barfuß aus dem haus getrieben
wird und dann hat man uns auf einen
sammelplatz geführt und daran uns
getrennt
nicht von meinen eltern hat man getrennt
wären meiner mutter noch 1 1 ein blick
geworfen
das war das letzte mal wenn der ganze
transport ist zur vernichtung gegangen
es ist ganz egal wo man sich eben dieses
ebenso da habe ich mir gedacht das ist
satz das leben für mich keine keine
keine bedeutung mehr
ich wollte mir das leben nehmen aber ich
habe nicht den mut gehabt jetzt das
leben zu nehmen
von jetzt an ist leon umgeben von mord
und gewalt von der barbarei der
deutschen
als man mich da abgeführt zu dem
sammelplatz das standlicht neben einem
offizier und der offizier
hier ist ein mädchen nahm das mädchen an
den haaren zog es hoch zu sein der
pistole und hat sie erschossen
das mädchen war sofort tot mit zither
bis hin so und ich habe noch nie in
meinem leben gesehen die man einen
menschen erschießt in münchen tot
schießen
etwa eine woche später ist auch leon
dran
sie holen ihn stecken ihn wie viel in
einen güterzug deportieren ihnen nach
auschwitz gefüllten zug ist man nach
auschwitz gefahren worden
lecker waren quibeldey notruf zu essen
und zu trinken wir haben sie einen nicht
gegeben
in auschwitz wird aus dem fabrikanten
sohn leo und schwarzbau meinen namenlose
nummer an dem tag wie ich angekommen bin
vor der baracke stand uns mit einer
häftling die ruhe nur eingraviert hat
hier in meiner hand rein gestochen hat
132 1624 das war mein name ich habe kein
name schwarzbau
ich habe nur ein nummer eine nummer
das war mein name
was leon nie vergessen wird der geruch
von auschwitz das roch entsetzlich die
schornsteine die rauchten ja
ununterbrochen und das handeln wir sehen
und das haben wir gerochen den geruch
war entsetzlich so ist sauer
da war alles verseucht die ganze erde
war da schon durchdringt
leon überlebt weil er als läufer für den
lager ältesten arbeitet er meldet wenn
ein ss-mann zu den baracken kommt er
sich das grauen die gaskammern
die leichenberge es ist vorgekommen
das ist kinder sich versteckt haben
unter den leichen und sind so davon
gekommen
leon wird zeuge wie häftlinge in
auschwitz ihre qualen beenden wollen im
hochspannungs stacheldraht
es gab ihm viele viele menschen wie sie
leben genommen haben
die menschen
die hingen in den räten
so sahen die toten aus indien drahtwaren
so wie ich jetzt zeigen
wir haben sich irgendwie war ich habe
nicht geglaubt dass ich dieses mal zu
überleben
doch leon damals 22 jahre jung ist stark
der kommt zu zwangsarbeit
eines tages kam nach auschwitz siemens
leute suchten schlosser und technischer
und und und und ich habe mich gemeldet
irgendwem genommen worden
leon ist nun ein siemens häftling im
außenlager braig bei auschwitz die
britschen beziehungsweise die die betten
der häftlinge die waren so wie in
auschwitz nicht anders wir hatten nur
wenige angst weil sie uns sich um uns
gekümmert haben
die haben nicht erlaubt dass die ss
leute das sagen in der halle haben die
durften da nicht mitreden
eine von leons aufgaben die sprengung
der schornsteine in der siemens fabrik
denn alliierte bomber rücken schon eher
könnten die schornsteine anvisieren
wir haben angst gehabt dass der
amerikaner die führung gewinnen ziehen
weg nach lassen nur noch rein knallen
rein bomben natürlich gemacht
erst im januar 1945 rückt die ostfront
so nah dass siemens seine zwangsarbeiter
richtung westen verlegt einen tag vor
der befreiung von auschwitz muss leon
das lager verlassen
er wird auf seinen ersten todesmarsch
geschickt 50 kilometer ist nach kleidet
zu fuß gelaufen
zu fuß in gleiwitz war auf der rampe
vallaster und da haben wir gewartet
nichts gegessen tage lang nichts
gegessen nicht wir haben uns nichts
gegeben haben sie nichts gehabt die
waren ja genauso wie auf der auf der auf
den todesmarsch regiert
und es geht es weiter mit dem zug die
nazi führung verschleppt die siemens
häftlinge die vorrückenden russen im
nacken
für leon geht es bei prag und eger nach
westen ins kz buchenwald vor den toren
von weimar wir da in das kleine lage und
kam rein und das sah ich meinen besten
freund innen kommando und da habe ich
ihm meine arbeit gegeben
das hat ihm geholfen auch scheinbar
immer bereits menschen zu helfen
am 20
februar 1945 an seinem 24
geburtstag geht s verlieren weiter nach
berlin siemensstadt kriegswichtige
produktion im fast schon verlorenen
krieg für unser lager war als ich hier
im lage war und wir hier zum abgang zum
aus zum abtragen von lebensmittel von
waggons gebracht wurden
wir waren zufrieden
es ist wieder weg sind vom großen
konzentrationslager
wir haben gewusst dass die uns hier in
denen sich um uns kümmern nicht sie wenn
es leute das war schon gar nicht mehr
wie ich richtig zu arbeiten
berlin war schon und herum
ich bin verschüttet worden durch die
bomben wie hier in die amerikaner und
engländer losgelassen ist eine bombe in
mein unterstand
eingekommen und sie haben glück gehabt
dass ich nicht verletzt wurde von beiden
seiten waren die eingänge verschüttet
und dann habe ich mal nach oben geguckt
und dann habe ich nicht gesehen
ein strahlen und dann haben wir mit den
händen gebuddelt
heraus gekommen ihr seid uns hier von
berlin noch mal im norden berlins
gefahren wo seit ich hingefahren
wir sind genau gefahren im westen und
wahnsinn auch privatleute mitgefahren
bürger von berlin sind damit gefahren
und sie haben angst gehabt wie sie uns
gesehen
es ist
mit karabiner und maschinenpistole
da haben sie weggeguckt ja es ist april
1945 das dritte reich steht kurz vor dem
ende
leon landet ganz zum schluss im kz
sachsenhausen
von hier wird er auch seinen letzten
todesmarsch geschickt 33.000 häftlinge
schleppen sich zu fuß von sachsenhausen
richtung schwerin fast 200 kilometer
haben sie menschen erschossen und werde
nicht laufen konnte und sie hingesetzt
hat der wurde beschlossen nichts zu
essen nichts zu trinken tage land wir
haben ja nur gras gefressen und bäume
blätter gefressen und also es sind
amerikanische truppen die leon nicht
weit von schwerin befreien
auf einmal sehe ich ein amerikaner sei
und aus dem wald aus dem hals gefallen
er kehrt nach berlin zurück heiratet
kinder hat er nie er wird
antiquitätenhändler mit einem laden nahe
dem kudamm ein gutes leben sagte
doch auschwitz und der holocaust lassen
ihn niemals los lange schweigt er über
die verbrechen
ich verlange ich aus über aussprechen
der plan war weil ich heute leben ich
wollte was vor ihm haben falls dieses
wollte tanzen gehen wollte
erst vor zehn jahren als fast 90-jährige
beginnt leon mit vorträgen vor schülern
freude macht mir das in die schule zu
gehen wir in der schule erzählen den
jungen leuten erzählen dass ich erlebt
habe
das macht mir spaß dass auch mit träume
ich mache dass sie meine freunde die
nicht überlebt haben
die umgekommen sind die verrückt sind im
lager nicht was für meine eltern ich tue
das auch mein volk tue ich nicht
die verbrechen waren ja so schlimm dass
ich keine vergebung bereit bin zu gehen
[Musik]
siemens hat eine geldentschädigung die
mehr haben
das waren welche 709.000 markt gewisse
genugtuung für mich das sind man sich
dann das geheimnis der erlösung heißt
die erinnerung das ist das wenigste
nehmen sich was man haben muss
da müssen meine familie immer das wurde
nicht vermisst sich sehr
ich bin der einzige der großen familie
liebe lebt ich erkläre das wird möchte
ich sagen erstens leidig furchtbar
darunter dass meine eltern nicht mehr
leben
die fehlen mir und zweitens warum wieso
menschen so seit seiner antisemitischen
ohne grund ohne ein zu kennen so zu sein
als ich in lage war in auschwitz habe
ich nicht geglaubt dass ich aus dem
schlamassel rauskommen aber dass ich 100
jahre alt werde
das habe ich nicht mehr das ist
heute verantwortung das ist
verpflichtung für uns verpflichtung
nämlich jeder neuen form der ausgrenzung
des rassismus und des antisemitismus
entgegenzutreten
es war ein gutes gespräch mit dem
präsidenten mehr und hoffnung
[Musik]
meine
heute bauen
[Musik]